>>Joseph: The collaboration with
the teachers fuels our students,
they get interested and
engaged and work on projects.
It just makes education real.
>>John: There are no
walls between departments.
The collaboration between the
academic and the vocational is one
of the core pieces of
what makes High Tech work.
>>Joseph: We accept students based
on interest, such as performing arts
or science, and with that goes
the hope that their interest
in their vocational program will drive
their interest and accomplishments
in their academic programs.
The integration between broadcasting and
the social studies started this year.
Mister Jefferson said, "I'd like to
bring my students into this studio.
Mister Pluchino, your
students could run the studio."
>>John: John and I sat down and
talked about doing a history show,
something where we can
invite the students.
The first week that I offered
the students the opportunity,
we could either sit here and do the
regular stereotypical history class,
or we could do a year's
worth of radio shows
and still learn the same
stuff, it was ten out of ten.
Everyone wanted to do the radio shows.
>>Good morning, welcome to another
episode of the Jeffersonian Show.
Today we'll be talking about Vietnam,
so let's talk about the protest
side of the Vietnam experience.
What are some of the protest songs
that stick out with some of you ladies?
>>Kelsey: There was one particular song
where it caused a lot of controversy.
It was, "You're old enough
to kill but not for voting."
In 1971, the US Constitution was amended
and they lowered the age,
the voting age to 18.
So music is not only a way to express
yourself, it's a way to make it change.
>>I'm just going to call
it really awesome.
My major is broadcasting and
now that I can combine history
and broadcasting together, it's a
very different approach to learning.
>>John: You think that the war was a
good idea to fight in the first place?
>>Student: The war was good to those
who were in the arms creating factory,
the bomb making, but as a country
it was bad, because we went
in blind and we lost a lot of men.
>>John: We have a planning session at
least once a week before we do the show.
John goes over the background
of the show.
The kids have to go home and research.
I want them to come informed,
you know, we just don't want,
"Yeah, I heard about that."
That doesn't make a show.
>>John: We'll have a goal and then
we'll backfill on how to reach the goal.
Thursday is the radio show and
Wednesday is the team teaching prep day
with John Pluchino.
The Monday and Tuesday, we'll
usually spend on instruction.
>>How should we open the show?
>>Student: We could lead up to
the Watergate scandal in the end.
>>John: They'll come to me with ideas,
so they'll read things on their own
and they'll bring me
articles that they've found.
They'll come up with bullet points
and things that they want to hit on
and we'll build a discussion
around those things.
>>Michael: We step away from the
textbooks, which is refreshing.
I like to bring what I've learned and
what I've exposed myself to the show.
>>Help prevented North and
South Vietnam from unifying,
because they didn't want them
both to become Communist.
A year after the war ended, the entirety
of Vietnam became Communist anyway.
>>John: The way we prep non-broadcasting
majors is we try to be basic
and simple, how to talk into the mic.
Learn how to listen to each
other, let the knowledge
that you have drive your communication.
>>John: The big thing with the skill
sets is not so much learning how
to operate the mechanics
of the broadcasting,
but how to be comfortable talking
to an audience that you can't see.
>>John: I consider the radio
station a great learning laboratory.
So it allows them to take the
next step with their studies.
>>Joseph: We have a collaboration
that gets the students more excited,
because they have a perspective
from two different areas.
>>John: Instead of just
writing book reports and tests,
they now can express
what they've learned.
I told the students, it's
larger than your grade.